es herrscht verkehrschaos bei bus und
bahn denn heute gibt es bundesweit einen
warnstreik im nahverkehr ausgerufen von
verdi mit dem streik soll ein
bundesweiter tarifvertrag von rund
87.000 beschäftigten durchgesetzt werden
mit massiven einschränkungen ist zu
rechnen wurde bereits vorher gewarnt
und all das eben in corona zeiten die
wenigen busse und bahnen die fahren sind
natürlich voll abstand kann nur schwer
eingehalten werden oder ist jetzt
einfach keiner gekommen weil man schon
vor geboren worden ist genau das möchte
ich jetzt einmal nach fallen bei unseren
reportern die in ganz deutschland jetzt
sich das angeschaut haben in berlin
hamburg und münchen mir nun zugeschaltet
sind meine kollegen und als allererstes
wollen wir einmal an den alexanderplatz
in berlin scheiden
dort steht für uns peter wege peter der
alexanderplatz einer der knotenpunkte
hier in berlin für die öffentlichen
verkehrsmittel ist dort jetzt chaos oder
absolute ruhe
jalil am alexanderplatz waren wir bis
gerade dort sind wir aber wieder weg
gegangen denn dort war es gerade nicht
so viel los am s-bahnhof die menschen
waren wohl vorgewarnt auf dem s-bahnhof
steig selber war nicht viel los die die
bvg streikte hier in berlin busse und u
bahnen fahren nicht deshalb war der
gesamte u bahnhof auch schon abgesperrt
wir sind jetzt hier zum frankfurter tor
gegangen um uns hier das ist einer der
straßen knotenpunkte hier sind immer
sehr viele autos unterwegs um hier uns
hier mal die situation anzuschauen
wir können das im hintergrund sehen ein
bisschen stau ist hier aber der ganz
große stau und das ganz große
verkehrschaos bleibt hier auf den
straßen berlins aber auch aus und ja die
s-bahn sind nicht ganz so voll
wir konnten auch mit einer frau sprechen
die uns gesagt hat ihr mann hat sie
jetzt mit dem auto zum s bahnhof
gefahren weil die u-bahn eben nicht
fahren und sie fährt dann mit der s bahn
weiter also hier werden so lösungen in
berlin gefunden also kein großer star
und corona abstand kann eingehalten
werden natürlich wenn man das auto nimmt
wie sieht das ganze denn in hamburg aus
michael klar ist schon dort michaela
klare entschuldigung
ja genau wir stehen hier am
jungfernstieg und das ist eben ein
solcher knotenpunkt wo die leute auch
von der s-bahn in die u-bahn
normalerweise steigen oder eben auch den
bus leben all das geht heute nicht bis
zum 12 uhr streiken noch
die u-bahn und auch die busse das war
eigentlich die neueste entwicklung hier
aus hamburg denn bis zuletzt hat die
hochbahn gehofft dass sie den busverkehr
zumindest halbwegs am laufen halten kann
die hoffnung wurden aber zerstört die
drei streikbereitschaft ist so hoch dass
auch der busverkehr jetzt komplett
lahmgelegt worden ist bis zum 12 uhr und
das sorgt dafür dass es gerade an den
bushaltestellen dann doch zu genervten
pendlern kommen viele haben verständnis
für den streik finden den zeitpunkt aber
eher unglücklich aber weitgehend sind
die hamburger eigentlich ganz gut
vorbereitet gewesen
sehr gute vorbereitung in hamburg jetzt
wollen wir noch einmal jakob male in
münchen fragen ob es dort genauso
aussieht bis 18 uhr sollen dort ja keine
u-bahn fahren ja das ist richtig und
zwar aus dem einen grund weil die
stadtwerke behindern wollen dass es zu
ansammlungen kommt deshalb die menschen
rein drängen weil eben die anderen
verkehrsmittel nicht bahn in münchen ich
stehe hier am sendlinger tor platz
es ist ein großer verkehrsknotenpunkt
die münchner an sich darauf eingerichtet
es ist kein kaum staub wohl hinter mir
auch eine baustelle ist unter mir fährt
normalerweise 4 u bahnlinien in alle
richtungen auch die trambahnlinie band
hier heute ist hier relativ eigentlich
gar nichts los ab und zu fährt eine
linie
ansonsten sind sehr viele fahrradfahrer
unterwegs und autos natürlich vielen
dank auch nach münchen für diese
einschätzung dank an die kollegen also
das große verkehrschaos ist zum glück
ausgeblieben aber bleiben sie weiterhin
vorsichtig denn auch wenn hier in berlin
und hamburg beispielsweise ab 12 alles
widerfahren soll kann es den ganzen tag
natürlich zu verzögerungen kommen mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bet schau dich jedes nächste video an
und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren